I'm 23 years old I have a job I've gone
to college I pay my bills and I'm
perfectly fine
when it comes to meeting hearing people
for the first time my experience is that
they always try to talk to me and I'm
like I can't hear so they think they can
speak louder but that's not really
helpful because I'm deaf
and then they will probably think that I
can read their lips not all deaf people
can do that
some can they're really good at reading
lips because they've been practicing
their whole life I read that the
multiple times you have to repeat huh
say it again
sometime people said never mind never
mind
and that kind of deaf people watching
know what's going on would you say don't
stay never mind
I want to know what you saying let help
me show you you know then I can help me
help you
sometimes when hearing people see deaf
people signing they think it means that
we're dumb or that the signing is wild
or an out of control and they don't
understand what it actually means
ISL American sign language is a language
a language that has its own formal
syntax grammatical structure first I'd
say it's a beautiful language and it's a
wonderful way to express yourself
it is a formally recognised language
aligned with any other language like
Spanish or French
so is being deaf a disability it's true
I don't hear certain things that those
of you who can hear are able to hear and
yet why should that be the focus on that
deficit way of thinking when instead we
could focus on all the good that life
brings to people who can't hear the
amazing things that people who are deaf
have as opposed to focusing on what it
is they don't have we are allowed people
because we will speak up for our
community we will protect our own we are
not a quiet subdued people I identify
myself as a black deaf woman even a pain
I'm symptom at the end of the day yes
I'd like to have my inflamed I can't
really really super spy I don't like it
I'm still struggling with my own
identity I'm fourth generation death my
grandparents and parents or death
so within deaf communities we have
people of all races and ethnicities we
have people who are gender
non-conforming and trans we have blind
and disabled people we have Coda's
children of deaf adults so the community
is much more rich and varied than most
people think
[Music]
there are some perceptions about the
deaf community that we are a very closed
community and that we're against spoken
English and the deaf communities against
cochlear implants often young deaf
people will find themselves and find
their identity whenever they become a
member of the deaf community where they
discover others who are like them we
don't fight we're actually a very
friendly open welcoming group and when a
hearing person connects to the deaf
community and learns how to sign it's a
beautiful thing and it's a beautiful
connection between that person and the
whole community you know we can be funny
we use body language we laugh and
hearing people give us a look sometime
and we have that same we have that same
humanity just tween them like a hearing
people they don't like the way you talk
slow hey hey my lip no just don't to say
hey my name is Jessica whatever I want
them to know that will come up to them
that will talk to them we can talk about
what we like to do what our names is
that we just want to talk to them we
want to have that chance and we have to
do that through acting and through
writing and through smiling but that's
that's all we want to do
[Music]
this video is part of a larger series on
the deaf community here are some of the
incredible people featured in this
series subscribe to catch all of these
amazing stories on this season of untold
America and let us know what community
we should cover next
[Music]
you